[music] [
music]
H [
Java Michael McFaul I am a professor at
Stanford University
A in political science and including I am a
research fellow at the Hoover Institution, a
researcher at the so-called GLI
Institute for International Relations, I am
the director of this institute
I have been for a long time
[music]
I was a professor here in 1995, I started
working here at Stanford and
still am
[music]
here I started studying Russian when
I was in my first
year in my
seventeenth year No no no in the
first year I started studying Russian
and I was worried that we had a
conflict between the Soviet Union and the United States I'm from
Montana By the way I was born there I lived
there for
years And when I got here at Ford as a
student that was the most
important thing to me This is a threat this is a confrontation
Cold War Regan just  won the
elections
and I wanted to find out and these are the Soviet people
to myself, not just what I read in the newspapers
Well, I wanted to see What the Soviet
Union is because of this I started studying
Russian I didn’t speak Russian but
keep in mind And I want this  say 100 times a
I studied Russian at Stanford
Yes in eighty-one I started and in the summer of
eighty-three I was at Leningrad State University
and Leningrad State
University and Summer School
I was here for a week I think I
studied again in 85  year It was the
Pushkin Institute in Moscow and then
I finished studying
[music]
Russian. I
think that I am a very bad student of the
Russian language. But I lived in Russia many times
and what did I understand? In the end,
I will speak with errors like now.
and sometimes when I was an ambassador I made
mistakes and they were serious
and problems we can maybe we will come back to
this but but I decided very early on myself
not to pay attention to my
all sorts of mistakes and if this is someone who
their
mind If you will about  you
will never talk about this, and this
was at first, I want to say that I was very
nervous all the time when I said
words or not, and I
thought about it psychologically all the time, and when
was this
breakthrough and Probably it
was 0 tenth and first year  I again
lived in Moscow In Moscow I mean Yes in
Moscow Moscow I just
did it Moscow
University State University
I was there and it was this year that I
finally realized that there is no need to bother And
how many mistakes will I say A
just try to communicate with people and
then when the Soviet Union collapsed
I started writing about Russia and without a word I
did a lot of interviews in
Russian I read in Russian I didn’t
write I didn’t eat food
in Russian very well Well it helped my scientific
work  Of course, without the Russian language I
could not write those books that
Stanford helped me get this job here Yes, this is the first and second and I
served the government Yes, I worked for 3 years
in the White House with President Obama I was responsible
for Russia and Central Asia on the
Security Council  and then 2 years in Moscow
as an ambassador I served as
[music]
ambassador my boss President Obama called
President Medvedev
And he Yes spoke to the shipyard and there he was an
interpreter Naturally yes And I sat on the
sofa and heard this conversation on another
phone yes  uh all this but there was
something And where was it It was obvious that the
translator did not
have time to translate And everything that was
said And after that I
spoke with Obama a few times and said This is what he
meant and I received trust from the
President  Obama And that I really
knew what we were talking about - weapons Afghanistan and
so on, well, but he also understood that I
understand the Russian language, because of this, he
invited me to all the meetings with Medve and
Putin
And and because he trusted me  that I can
help him when it comes to the plot,
what the plot is about, and the language. And there was even
one very critical case.
And we did this, and the
agreement with Russia when I worked in the
White House is called in Russian,
this is in English, this is New  in my opinion in
Russian it’s START-3 And if I’m not mistaken
And there was a very critical moment when
we decided that we had an agreement
and suddenly And there was such a big disagreement
with the media about the
issue, by the way Naturally,
and I won’t detail this  very difficult, but there
was one moment when I realized that
someone on our team was saying something to the
IR team which was not right and
which was not our position. I knew our
positions since I
oversaw foreign policy on Russia from the
White House, and so did I.  was there for a few
minutes I finally understood it and I
went up to Obama and he was sitting on the phone and
he kept saying why Medvedev kept
saying that I don’t understand what he was talking about but
I understood all this and I approached him I
wrote  Yes, and I have a very bad manuscript,
by the way,
in English many times already in
Russian, I wrote for him What is it about
because I understood in Russian
Medvedev A and and then he understood and he
should
say something and which was
100  % differences and which our diplomats
said and it was a very tough
conversation and he was very
not How to say He is a very moderate
person by the way Obama Yes And this time
He was upset Well because of this it
was very
useful for this conversation and in  in the
end, we signed this agreement And by
the way, I can show this I I just
remembered This is where this call is And what did
I just talk about and it was
without the Russian language I couldn’t do it
and the latest on this topic I’m just finishing
Well  of course he will be an ambassador and does not
say to be an ambassador to Russia do not speak
Russian and there are many who did not speak
Russian did not speak Russian
or the Russian language
yes Well, when I became an ambassador I
tried to speak Russian all the time both on
television and in  on the radio I even gave
lectures in Russian
and and and several times I made mistakes
naturally, but this without a
word helped me to have contacts with
Russians this is Rossi this I feel
it all the time A and I can’t imagine
how to do this work And without  a-a
ae Russian
[music]
language oh I didn’t decide anything and Obama decided
but I explain and I’ll explain
And I worked for his election
campaign for 2 years
a My colleague My
friend her name is Susan Rice and
she supervised such Team A for foreign
politics for Obama And I must say
that I myself At first I knew Obama very little,
but I trusted Susan Rice and
connected him to Team A and when we
won And
then there was such a transition process and I
mean that
there were doubts if I would work on the
Security Council  And my backup job And
by the way, it was to become an
ambassador of Ukraine, it was in 2008, it’s
interesting to think about it today
Well, purely because of this, it
was I was on the election campaign and
then I worked in the White House and then  yes, I
was a political figure Yes, not not a
professional figure I don’t know this
word, but this is their word, I think I’m a
professional person,
but well, in our system, that’s how it happens Yes, and that’s
how it happens, too. We usually have
outsiders, yes, that is, those who are not  in the
state government Well, as
professors usually They serve for about 2
years even less Yes and then let's go back to
work Like how I'm working at
Stanford now and that was my plan by
the way And that was what I offered for
my family
which they  it didn’t matter to live in
Washington, but after 2 years they want to
return home and we had such a
great agreement in this regard and I
talked to my
boss and said well, we had a good
time but I need to come back and he said
No, you can’t now  we have too
much
work and then he talked to Obama and
Obama said the same thing that Michael can’t
leave now we need to try to
find an opportunity for him to stay and in the
end
the offer from the White House from Obama
was
ahh to continue working  in the
Obama administration, well, do new work
and
more Friendly as a friendly for
this life and that’s just how I became the
ambassador of Russia that is, and because of this, well,
it was a long process as we have Well, that’s
how I became such an unexpected
ambassador for me  to
Russia
[music]
Well, unfortunately, there are huge opportunities.
And if 30 years later And when the collapse of the
Soviet Union was the end of the Cold War, the
end of history, as my colleague Fuki Yama
wrote Yes, and he is a professor at
Stanford University and after that
Well, there were two trends in  first there was
the opportunity to live in Russia and do
business and I worked at the Think Tank
Moscow Carnegie Center and from the very
beginning and it was a very good time
to be in Russia by the way and an interesting
time they wanted to establish democracy and
market economies and be friends with
America and  it was such a wonderful time.
Well, because of this, many people thought that, well,
Russia was no longer important and the other trend
was unimportant now we need to study
Chinese and here Stanford
students who studied Russian fell
after that Nuno now and
again I want to emphasize K
unfortunately, the threat to Russia and the problem
from Russia from Putin and his dictatorship is
growing And of course, first of all, this is a
terrible sad war And which he
is doing now in Ukraine
Well, I’m counting again
Unfortunately And this will be Russia will be
very big for America  strategically a
problem for foreign policy and we
need people who speak Russian. And
this was very obvious when I was
ambassador, this is already 8 years ago, I
mean, but my age Yes, the people who
were closer to me were very experienced,
such a team and  I had just a
wonderful team, they all spoke
almost all the highest
levels, they spoke excellent Russian.
But these were people who began to
study Russian during the Cold
War, yes, during the Soviet Union,
and average diplomats, they did not speak
Russian.
And we had a great  deficit I would
say
even
now it is obvious to me I communicate a lot
with people in government now this is
mine We all worked together When
I worked with Obama Well including
President Biden and his entire team they
all And we we all worked together yes but
they have people who speak Russian,
but quite a bit a-a And we need to
provide a reserve of
people who understand the Russian language.
I think this is a strategic priority
for America today, the Chinese language and
Russian
[music]
language, of course, without conditions. I’m very glad that
You ask me this because you forget this a lot,
but there is a feeling I now work on
television Yes on nbc and sometimes I
have a feeling when I spoke with the presenters
as if all the time Russia was evil
Horrible
And
I am the enemy of America, this is not so first of all  if you
study lokom our stories, now I am writing
a book on this one which begins from the very
beginning of America and 250 years ago
we
had a time when we also had a good
attitude and people forget about it they
helped us during our Revolution they did
not
support the Southern states  during the
Civil War and and after when there was a
democratization of the Revolution of this year before the
Bolsheviks
seized seized power there was also
a moment where we were very close and then
under Gorbachev and Elena there was a
very such time I lived in Russia and in the
Soviet Union during  this
period of Gorbachev and Elna and we had a
lot that we did together and even came to
the shipyard between the first and second
rounds of President Putin and the third round there
was a time when we really did a lot
together, we signed START-3, which
we already talked about and we worked  together
against Iran
And We worked together to provide for
our soldiers in Afghanistan When our
soldiers arrived, they flew through Russia
and to Kyrgyzstan and then to Afghanistan Well,
well, such
cooperation should go back to the first
World War II so that this would be the
last time that American Soldiers
if possible  I’m wrong but I think I’m
right and this was the last time
American Soldiers flew through
Russia And Russia joined the WTO and by the way we had money
in
2010 I have this data I
wrote a book on this topic and I can
do  small advert
and I have data there and uh in the tenth
year and
60% of the Russian population had a good uh
view of America and
55% of Americans had the same but
positive view of Russia this
was only 8 years ago that is
and this is now  it’s terrible Yes now it’s
worse than
uh Brezhnev’s time I think But that doesn’t
mean that it will be the same forever but
there is time and there is a history where it
was uh different and I’m a big optimist and because of
this I have hope for
[music  ]
the future
since Putin remains in power I don’t
see the opportunity for any
restructuring of attitudes or
a reset No, I don’t see I know Putin we
met for the first time, by the way, in the
ninety-first year That is, we have a
long history and 5 years I worked with him
ae government  I wrote a lot about him And
I know his entourage and I know his
rivals and I just don’t see such an
opportunity with him to work with
the Americans, but he will be in power
forever and and after Putin when that
will be I don’t know And after him for now  and
I think that such a time
will be an opportunity for something new,
and keep in mind that after Stalin there was
de-Stalinization and the Krushov period. And I
think there will probably be the same
movement, and there are polls that
show that
young people are educated people, rich
urban people  people and this part of the
population of Russia this part does not
support Putin and wants to establish better
relations with Europe and
[music]
America Oh, I can’t answer that I’m a
diplomat after all Well,
what a beautiful city St. Petersburg
Leningrad is When I lived there And what
interesting people  And since I’m involved in
politics
[music]
Moscow
No, but I’ll think about it I love a lot but
one of them says Well, probably If you
need one, the Karamazov brothers, yes
And I just read this book in
Russian when I was a student not at all of
AE and this  was my first Experience very
deeply and feel the Russian Russian
text Yes, that's why it had a great
impression on
[music]
me to study the
Russian language If you want to be in
Moscow or or Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan and
so on there are many countries where you
can serve and uh the language is the most  the main thing is
to study history
And this was very useful for me that I
knew the History of Russia and the Soviet Union
And the third
[music]
and understands it is necessary to study and use
Your entire biography in order to be a
good public
diplomat yes
And I thought when I was in Moscow that we are
not  we didn’t do too much
Public diom, yes, that is, public
diplomacy
And this was our weak point and to
do it correctly you need to say that I’m
from Montana and I love Stanford I love
American football and
find your biography
will be useful for your work like
[music  ] a
diplomat, that is, a specific person, yes
Well, Alexei
Navalny and we need to study Who he
really is, not what propagandists say about NM, but
well, I think that he is a hero And he is such a
figure, you rarely come across the world
ae and and understand him And how he thinks and
what does he think
and I don’t know what will happen to him next?
Yes, he’s in jail now, but I don’t know if
he will be,
but will he be free? No But his ideology And I
think it’s extremely important, and if not him, then
his team Yes, the second person  in this
team which I think is very important
to know how she thinks and and her name is love
[music]
so
Y